[Applaudissements]
bah oui on le mail à chaque fois ça
tombe sur la gueule voilà ces chauffards
ça va zy jamais réussi
[Rires]
c'est important
bombay inde
m
sans emploi
alors attention c'est normal première
question tout est normal bien sûr quel
jeu quel jeu présente nagui quel jeu
présente nagui à temps il a jamais la
jamaïque et si l'argent n'est plus à
nackawic serait non ça va alors que sony
donnera tous les autres bien sûr mais la
présente nagui sur france 2 tous les
jours à munich
attention mesdames est la preuve et mais
la poule b la trahison la place avec le
monde veut prendre sa place
ouais pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
je voulais tout le monde veut prendre sa
place très bonne réponse de prétention
attention attention prenez chacun un
petit verre les chéris fédéraux mise et
de l'huile de foie de morue
c'est très bon
vous inquiétez pas c'est vrai [ __ ]
avant de baisser les bras
ça fait quoi dire vous allez voir vous
allez attention attention je pose la
question
ces deux lits quelle attention voici la
question sur quelle chaîne est diffusée
l'émission crime de jean marc tanguy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nrj12 web
voilà
très mal
je prenais des attentions là il va
falloir mettre tous les chamallows dans
la bouche vous répondre avant cela
attention attendait voici la question
aimez moi j'ai me connais je sais plus
quel de quelle émission de télé dans
quelle émission télé poteau voir les
candidats affichent sur play souple et
gilles en poudre est riche à pape diop
et dans quelle émission de télé peut-on
voir les candidats retirer des couteaux
d'un fourreau sur m6 avait tous les
talents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la toile a parlé de minarets car été
donnée la juste un mec qui kiffe le chat
mâle mon coin
j'adore cela
[Applaudissements]
vous madame vous madame c'est non qu'est
ce que les époux cet autre moi cette
trêve qui a gagné voilà bah je vous le
dis bravo pas être converties à l'état
sauvage de mardi